[Applause]
[Music]
guys this is the last episode of new
releases before e3 so before you get
excited about all the games coming out
over the next few months let's take a
look at some of the biggest ones
launching this month June has fighters
sushi chefs dinosaurs tennis players and
Nazis boy one of those things is really
not like the others but hey let's start
with the fighter blaze Blue Cross tag
battle takes the already crazy world of
blaze blue and crosses over with other
universes letting you Duke it out with
characters from persona 4 arena under
night in birth and our waby now that
just covers the cross part of cross tag
battle the tag part means two on two
fights where you can tag in your partner
with a roster of 40 characters that's a
ton of possible duo's ready to throw
down the battle begins on ps4 PC and
Nintendo switch on Tuesday June 5th or
later in the month on the 22nd in Europe
and if you just can't wait that long you
can check out some of the games suite
finishers on GameSpot right now
sushi striker the way of sushi dough is
all about battling your opponents too
but in a very different way this action
puzzle game challenges you to connect
similarly colored plates of sushi so you
can fling them at your opponent and
drain their health bar you can also
power up your sushi sprites to totally
turn the tables on your enemies whether
it's in the story mode or in competitive
multiplayer and did I mention that sushi
is actually banned in this world I guess
it's time to fight the man by throwing
raw fish at him
sushi striker hitstun Tendo switch and
3ds on friday june 8th but june isn't
just home to video games as Jurassic
world evolution is launching alongside
its movie cousin Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom if you're a fan of dinosaurs and
park management you'll be right at home
here as evolution is all about building
your own Jurassic Park between 40
species of dinosaurs three branches of
development and tons of park facilities
to choose from you
seemingly endless options to help life
find a way you can do that on ps4 Xbox
one and PC on Tuesday June 12 I'm sure
you're all excited to hear that classic
theme song again on the sports side of
things everyone's favorite Italian
plumber is heading back to the court
with Mario Tennis aces this latest entry
is really shaking things up and not just
because it's the first mario tennis game
and forever to have a real story mode
you can also dominate the court with
specially aims own shots time-bending
zone speed sneaky trick shots and
ultimate special shots as you'd expect
you can also take all the tennis action
online for multiplayer matches and if
you feel like swinging a racquet
yourself you can totally play using
jaikon motion controls you can take a
swing only on Nintendo switch on Friday
June 22nd the Nintendo switch is also
getting a hefty port this month with
Wolfenstein - if you missed out on BJ
blaskowitz his latest battle you'll now
be able to take the war anywhere you can
totally use the joy cons to aim your
guns but you can also use the pro
controller gyros to fine tune your shots
beyond that you'll be in for the same
fan favorite Nazi killing campaign that
came to other consoles last year
Wolfenstein - finally lands on
Nintendo's switch on Friday June 29 and
those are some of the biggest games
we'll be playing all month long as
always remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and as a heads up new releases
we'll be taking a week off for e3 so
I'll see you guys back here in two weeks
with more June games